hi I went to start with saying thank you
so much for 5000 subscribers I know it's
not that much but it really means a lot
to me and I'm not even like I know it's
a cliche but it actually does because if
it weren't for the fact that I've got so
many subscribers I would have dropped
this game a very long time ago and
probably shot myself up in my room and
then watch anime all day and become
nothing so thank you for saving me from
that so onto the questions we have the
first one we have are you a virgin
okay so we're off to a great start and I
don't think I really need to answer this
this isn't [ __ ] true so dare but I I
play roller coaster tycoon 3 and make
videos of that all day what do you think
who is best pony definitely gonna go
with Colgate and the meaning of life was
to be very honest my opinion on the
meaning of life is there is no meaning
of life life is useless and life itself
is just it came about by evolution I
guess
oh how in whatever way it like I don't
even care how life actually came into
existence
it's useless anyway because anything
will ever do or will even think of doing
it's gonna be a blitz rate by the grand
scheme of the universe things anyway and
we can't even be sure that life even
exists the way that we know it does so
all I can say is just don't give a crap
about that and just live your life as
you want and have loads of fun because
that's probably the only thing you can't
really do and how much YouTube money do
you make well I can't give an exact
answer to that but I can say YouTube
money do you smoke weed every day no
obviously not
it's not a good idea to smoke weed every
day if you do you're probably addicted
and it's not healthy and it is addictive
unlike many people think so don't do it
why no you choose rollercoaster tycoon I
don't know it probably chose me I don't
really know I just like playing it now
if you're talking about why I choose to
upload rollercoaster [ __ ] videos and not
anything else since I did play a lot of
SimCity and a lot of Minecraft and such
games in my life I
just haven't ever made videos though of
them because I simply feel like I don't
have anything unique to offer in those
games so yeah I just want to make what
videos that I think I have something to
give that others may not have so that's
why I'm only uploading roller-coaster
Khun Watts plays at the moment now
favourite rct3 youtuber and that's
either inactive or active most likely n7
simply because he's made my favorite ICT
3 roller coaster ever Nero is made
awesome custom scenery and his stuff is
just amazing though to be fair jrc age
is very close second with arm putter and
when it comes to let's plays flex trance
is the best okay name three things that
you like and hate about the Netherlands
oh let's see I really like the candies
and cookies and all that and probably
also the fact that you can pretty much
write your bike everywhere that's
awesome like why is the rest of the
world not doing that also the fact that
it pretty much made everything legal
that the rest of the world hasn't I'm
like weed abortions gay marriage
prostitution everyone should just decide
for themselves what they want to do now
there are some things I hate about the
Netherlands yeah the entire idea of
taking a plot of land that's only needs
sea level and then build cities on it
and then go apeshit when it turns out
that the entire country floats like holy
[ __ ] what did you expect and just the
fact that people just keep living here
and then there's the fact that Dutch
people as soon as anybody in the world
notices the fact that Holland exists or
the Netherlands rather that it exists
they just go apeshit and and think the
famous or something everyone's just so
nationalistic now let's see your Luck's
up your Luck's in a room with Justin
Bieber Miley Cyrus and Nicki Minaj you
have to bullets a bullet holy [ __ ]
[ __ ]
and a gun who do you shoot obviously
myself and the questions ROFL do you
like bananas yeah yeah bananas are
pretty cool now if you were on the
laptop what weed would you smoke when
jerking off to Miley Cyrus I don't this
is very inappropriate but native eatery
to eat
let's see when's the next time you're
gonna know cut it off now can you make
list of all the mods you use not really
but ivory uploaded my style theme so if
you want to get all of the mods that I'm
using you can go to my about page and
download it so let's see if you if you
could pick one thing what would be your
dream feature in ICT world an undo
button going to be amazing
now a couple of questions what do you
expect a roller coast icon world I don't
exactly know I think it's gonna be
pretty cool but I don't think it's
really going to replace roller coaster
code 3 unless it's going to feature the
custom scenery and the best roller
coaster I've been on in real life this
is the wild mouse and really awesome
after Ling has a new coaster in the
construction and blah blah blah blah
blah what do you think of that it's
pretty cool finally some decent rides in
the Netherlands I guess and my favourite
Park global that I would like to visit
is probably Europa Park or some Disney
lion or Disneyland in Hong Kong actually
would also be amazing a favorite
amusement park yard like I just said
Disneyland Hong Kong is actually
probably my favorite and I would rather
have a cure for Ebola because I'm
secretly kind of scared of it and no
face come do you like the name no I
actually don't like my own name it's
just the way it's pronounced the fact
that it's French that's sorry French
people but holy [ __ ] I don't really like
my name so yeah do my classmates know
that I'm a YouTube legend okay first of
all I'm not a YouTube legend and second
yeah they know I remember that we had a
barbecue when this came out and everyone
was drunk and they all went her YouTube
money and they kept asking me how much
money I was earning and that was hella
anoying any idea when noscope 3 is
coming out soon I'm working on it but at
a very very slow pace because I I'm not
that motivated and I did make a
Slenderman the ride but the five nights
at Freddy's is never going to happen
because Slenderman the ride really
really sucks honestly let's see what
when you do custom scenery what window
system do you run well regardless of
whether what custom scenery I use I use
Windows 7 so I guess that's that my
biggest hope for ICT world like I said
is unloop button also the graphics need
to be good
I got into rollercoaster tycoon in the
whole YouTube thing well I I played a
lot of roller coaster tycoon 1 & 2 in my
childhood so I moved on to Ronco second
3 as soon as it came out and I think I
got into the YouTube thing because of
some people on Facebook and also
watching videos from men on a mission 1
2 3 and Murphy engineer and my favourite
type of roller coaster definitely the
pipeline coaster are you silver at oh
you silver at do you make new chip money
do you make YouTube money yes which is
better robots that can transform into
cars and it's transformers sucks nuts
that's basically it I can hug you know
yeah my face is very fabulous I don't
know how that happened I guess it's
magic Illuminati confirmed yes is your
favorite color
also Carrie okay can we get some serious
questions now and no my favorite color
is blue what is your favorite game
besides ICD 3 probably Pokemon emerald
simply because nostalgia and I really
love that game though I also have played
a lot of minecraft in my life but I
don't like it as much as of lately boobs
or buns I'm gonna go with personality
and PC my favorite roller coaster in the
world is the wild mouse that really was
my favorite roller coaster on YouTube
like I've said it's nero by and 7 and
noscope the right three is coming up
soon stop asking questions about noscope
the right three it's not that great
whereas your chances of you doing a
co-op series with me when i CT world is
released somewhat good i guess that's
when rollick at least when rollercoaster
tycoon world is not going to screw up I
would actually love to do some nice
co-op stuff with people so yeah that
would be awesome so I really hope that
it's going it's going to work out like
that I I will do more theme parks to do
though I must admit I'm not that great
at it and I haven't played it that much
especially compared to how how much
other people have been playing it and
I've actually finished one video already
so I need to get to rendering that and
uploading it but I won't play it as much
because I don't want it to replace well
like Oh second three simply because I'm
more a more of a scenery person and so
forth theme park studio hasn't really
convinced me it's too beta I only shower
using show fronting yes definitely
you stole that question but whenever
it's still cool if there was an MMO
based on rollercoasters would you play
it it's funny I just watched sword art
online but yeah I think I would actually
play it now and actually be pretty funny
and I can make videos of it that'd be
awesome
what inspired you to do your YouTube
videos I'm probably man on a mission one
two three I can vaguely remember that he
was the one who really inspired me to
get into this and honestly I never ever
expected 5 K subs even if I when I had
1k subs it took me like three years to
get to 1k so never really expected to
get 5 K at that point but all the way in
the beginning when I had 20 subs over
the course of a couple of months and the
only one who would comment on my videos
was my dad I didn't expect anything I
don't even know how I got the motivation
to keep making videos in that time and
the best roller coaster I've ever been
on is the wild motions really definitely
my face looks like beautiful look at it
oh my god that's amazing
I I have no celebrity crush no I don't
see the point of celebrities it's stupid
it's sheep mentality and no but yeah
some celebs are pretty cool I think I
had a crush on Scarlett Johansson when I
was very young her favourite coaster
that I've made damn this is actually
very hard question I don't really have a
favorite but I think at the moment it's
it's real gone yeah and I would like to
do a disney style park with fantasy
castles and all that but I don't know I
usually just built whatever I feel like
doing so I don't know if I really ever
feel like doing that my favorite songs
are artists are actually nothing like
the music I put in my Let's Plays I I
only use like the copyright free slash
EDM music so I don't even like it that
much so thank you but actually I don't
like it myself
I usually I listen to everything every
genre really there's no particular genre
now listen to but as of lately I've been
listening a lot to save ins Red Hot
Chili Peppers and rhythm temptation
which is a very weird combination I
think I asked you this before but what
gave you the inspirations to actually
make rollercoasters specifically and if
you write them blah blah blah no I
actually don't like roller coaster
anything I'm not a coaster enthusiasts
and the only thing that inspired me to
make rock
specifically is the gameplay of Rolla
Coast a country and that's pretty much
it I just love being creative like aside
from like roller coaster second three I
also make music I do writing and drawing
and all that and just making
rollercoasters and the community is what
got me into it what is an Oct 3
expansion pack that you always wanted I
guess if I could come up with my own I
would love it to have an expansion pack
that would allow you to build cities as
in Sim City but then with more
customization like roller coaster code 3
and do you think RCT world will be
better than rct3 I actually don't I
can't say anything about this because
it's obviously all about opinions but
when it comes to my opinion so far I
actually think that I city 3 with all
the custom scenery is better than what
they have with ICT worlds so far but I
don't dislike it ok now there's a lot of
swearing and ironic montage memeing
going on in this one which is very
inappropriate I'm not even gonna bother
to answer that but definitely flyover
inverts intamin over B&M and both of my
parents yeah why don't you just press C
to rotate stuff yeah this is something
that I've known for years and I still
haven't ever done it and it's very
strange also why you see your left eye
glass bigger than your right one on your
profile pic because because I the next
question why do you hate the most
who do you hate the most from all the
people on the earth I don't hate anybody
I wish the world could just be everyone
on fluffy pink clouds with unicorns and
cupcakes that would be amazing but sadly
the world is not like that
do you swag definitely III swag tan a
maximum swaggin one hundred thousand one
hundred trillion oh god damn base god no
let's see what's your favorite CTR mmm
this is actually really hard but it's
probably codemasters bnm sit-down or
flawless one of the two and I don't even
know what baby Snow Leopard is so but I
guess I'd be a fan of it because it
sounds pretty cool and penguins are
pretty cool they don't bother me or
anything
and how would someone awesome like you I
have no clue how old aren't you
I am not 50 years old what number is
your favor this confuses me but if I
would associate numbers with the
caller's I associate the number five
with blue so I'm gonna go with five and
your parents hate you because you're
adopted and why not finish Ashe bridge
because one does not simply finish
IceBridge and what's your favorite color
scheme for a roller coaster it's that
one one one arrow dragon thingy in Hong
Kong now has a awesome color scheme
Snoop Dog a weed Snoop Dogg definitely
spider-man over Superman and like I've
said before intimate over bina
definitely no gay over again or because
I'm homophobic but simply because I'm
not gay but Garagiola is probably better
than going in so yeah and ICT 3 is
better than ICT to attraction czar
button and coasters and definitely
building a night with ICD 3 if you see
my live streams I'm always like okay I'm
home alone I've got the entire night for
myself I can go fap but I could also go
play roller coaster Co 3 and I'm also
always gonna go for a lolly coast icon 3
I'm that person
do you prefer to drink bleach or eat
batteries while some people at fortune
told me to drink bleach and that was
pretty cool so I'm gonna with go with
bleach where do you get your custom
scenery in tracks all of them add custom
scenery depot.com it's an awesome site
I am NOT a girl gamer [ __ ] how [ __ ]
girl gamers ok I'm sorry but girl game
is a damn terrible ending any girl who
respects games and respects to herself
and other people shouldn't call yourself
a girl gamer because that terms been
deluded by girls just forcing their
their gender and being sexist and
showing their boobs and just or all
about the money and it's very annoying
you you're a gamer regardless of whether
you're a boy a girl a pen pen the sexual
or and any of the things in between and
your gender shouldn't matter so girl
gamers I know because boy gamers don't
even exist when was the last time you
get shrekt inappropriate montage me mean
goes unanswered let's see do you have a
degree in coaster building no actually
just they're not very accurate to
real-life coasters simply because roller
coaster in three restrictions and
honestly I would not even
think about getting a degree in coaster
building I don't even find them that
interesting
I can't lick my elbow because that's I
think that's impossible
for anyone and I also can't explain
Stephen Hawking's black hole theory
because that is also impossible for
anyone McDonald's Burger King of KFC
none of those things I prefer to eat
real food but KFC is probably better
because they that chicken doesn't taste
like plastic how old are you I'm 17 my
favorite color is 17 I I love you very
much
FaceCam is will happen at some point I
guess but not now and which flavor ice
cream strawberry cheesecake is the best
my voice is very sexy because I I drink
milk every day and I have one sister my
room looks like stupid except except I
do have a Finding Nemo poster so that's
pretty cool my PC specs are terrible I I
wait I don't even know how much I weigh
my table is wooden no and I don't know
what kind of wood it is but it seems
like oak wood and it's if 3 minus 2 is 1
I am loominatee ok I'm sorry how do you
shoot a real gun now that is a very hard
question you first have to acquire
expert powers so that's gonna be very
hard for me seems like you would be
training to be an architect or maybe you
are no none of those things I'm not even
gonna I'm not even gonna do that because
mathematics and all that how do you make
good coastal layouts mmm it takes
practice about let's see about 10 years
of flexes I think yeah that's why I have
what made you start playing roller
coaster second three my childhood roller
coaster second one and two and then
three came out and I was just like mom
get that for me and she did so thank you
mom and I started YouTube by clicking on
create account and then I entered all of
the things that I needed to enter how
long do you play roller coaster second
three already yeah since the launch of
ICD 3 yeah so for way too long and
pretty much without brakes really except
for a couple of few month breaks for
stuff like minecraft two other terrible
[ __ ] make the most make the most random
coaster ever mmm not really
I think well no scope is random enough
I'd say England or USA Canada how did
you become so good at rollercoaster
country
lock yourself up in your room play it
24/7 get lack of social contacts and no
life it and after about ten years of
doing that you'll probably get pretty
good at it my religious beliefs I am
agnostic
so it's not really too personal because
I'm on neither side of the atheists
versus Christians debate though they're
both stupid for a debating that [ __ ] you
should just keep it for yourself
everyone should just believe what they
want to believe and I don't believe
anything because I believe you can't
believe
well you can't prove anything so I don't
want to believe anything that you can't
prove sorry for being so complicated why
does Ebola Chan have such a big impact
on your life because Ebola Chan is life
and can you please do a Park Recreation
series know I've said this before it I
don't do recreation simply because I
feel like there's not enough creativity
involved I want to make my own stuff and
recreations it's just something that I
don't find as fun because it's not
really all of my own input but I think
that some people actually recreating
Cedar Point and other things but I'm not
entirely sure do you like riding
coasters in real life actually no
because I'm [ __ ] scared of them
oh and hi thanks for that thanks for the
congratulations and rct3 creators that
inspired you well in the beginning like
I said men on a mission one two three
Murph the engineer but to this day and
seven inspires me krch let's see Liam
and hath hath even many people actually
almost all of the people at Chagos world
in a sense and it's more of a suggestion
but would you like one of your coasters
to be commenting on my tin Rob Alfie yes
holy [ __ ] this is a wish that I didn't
know I had if Rob Alvia would actually
do that on one of my videos my life
would be complete I wouldn't have
anything to do anything else to do on
this earth I would just be like okay
this is it
good no that would be so amazing so I
wish you would do that but I don't think
it's gonna happen what made you start
playing roller coaster second three
Monaco second one
- how did you start YouTube by clicking
create account how did you come up with
the name self Rhett it's a very creative
name oh thank you but it's actually not
that creative because it's just a sort
of an abbreviation of my real name I
just took some letters out from the
first spots for my enormous Lane for my
enormous name sorry it's it's just a
gigantic it's a French thing
it's holy [ __ ] is huge and I just took
cup off the first letters have jump up
them around and then I got silver and I
was like yeah okay but might mind you I
was 12 when I came up with the name so I
don't even like it that much though I am
really glad that I can now I didn't come
up with king of coasters xxx 1 2 3 or
something like that and will you ever
release your let's play Pike when you
finish it or is it just for show
purposes
yeah like Verona Valley I'm not gonna
release it anymore simply because
there's so much custom scenery had so
much more than going on that for 95% of
the people who downloaded Verona Valley
it crushed that game it didn't work it
cost load of time so I felt like I'm
just not gonna bother with this anymore
it's not really helping anyone
so yeah I'm sorry but I don't want to go
through everything like that anymore and
I also don't want other people to
download something and try and get it to
work when eventually it doesn't even
work anyway so that's that what do you
want to do with your life are you really
thinking about thinking to play rct3 or
next years no no never ever I'm not
gonna make money with just YouTube makes
no sense even if I had a million subs I
wouldn't even do this I wouldn't even
think about doing this because it's not
anything that all save you in the future
in the next 30 years perhaps YouTube
well disappeared is it's gone down I
capitalism is gone
communism is everywhere III you just
don't know what's gonna happen in the
future so I am want to at least secure a
job that's a real job and actually get
educated and go to university so no I'm
not gonna make money off of youtube
not to mention that with only 5 thousand
subs you barely make any money can you
do another alpine village build already
on it from where comes to music on
verona valley it's so beautiful two
steps from hell
they're awesome sadly though I had to
take down all of my old videos because
of to stuff from how music because
copyright claims well I can't I think of
a good question then that's that's quite
a paradox since I consider that question
a pretty cool a good question so that's
really nice
why do you like ICT 3 I like it partly
because of the community it's really
nice but also just the fact that you can
import anything and therefore build
anything in the game and the only limit
is your own imagination and there's
there are rarely any games if there are
any that have the same that work in the
same way my craft is very similar but my
craft is kind of taken over by minigames
and the children and basically also the
graphics are less good so roller coast
echoing 3 all the way who is your waifu
definitely Rico Sutton from Tortuga
cocoon a real gun so yeah that was my
Q&A video hope you enjoyed and asked any
question that you wanted to ask because
I can't say for sure that I'm ever going
to do this again I probably might not
because this turned out into a disaster
and I to make a mathematics test
tomorrow and [ __ ] happened like
basically I was like okay I've got the
four thousand nine hundred and seventy
eight subscribers I won't have to worry
about anything I can make my monster
test well tomorrow and studying all that
and then suddenly overnight I get 25
subscribers like what what's up with
that please don't do that ever again
now that's why I need it to kind of
hurry up with this and [ __ ] homework
anyway so now I'm gonna fill that test
so yeah that's awesome also add way too
many comments I felt like I would maybe
get like 50 at max but now it's more
than 100 so that was pretty cool
but yeah thanks for watching and bye